Speaker 1: So we've talked about ivermectin.
We've talked about people using iodine,
sometimes sold under, I guess it's like the trade
name Betadine, and now we have to talk about
inhaling hydrogen peroxide vapor. An article
on health dotcom titled No Inhaling Hydrogen
Peroxide Vapor to Cure covid won't work.
Doctors warn, please do not do this.
The covid-19 pandemic has brought questionable
treatments. It mentions ivermectin. Others are
now reportedly inhaling hydrogen peroxide.
The Asthma and Allergy Foundation of America
released a warning this week urging people
not to try this dangerous treatment trend
that's making the rounds on social media. Some
users claim that putting hydrogen peroxide into
a nebulizer, that's a breathing machine that
turns liquid asthma medication into a mist
and then breathing in the mist will help cure
covid-19. Many social media sites are flagging
and yanking videos and claims, but screenshots are
still showing up. Someone named Ryan Graney posted
friends. Our vaccines will no longer be valid.
On October 20th, white and ivermectin will reign
supreme. They are going to burn their damn lungs
off three percent. Food grade hydrogen peroxide in
a nebulizer or a small syringe. You can squirt it
in your nose. Add sailin to it if it's too harsh.
The Facebook post from a naturopathic doctor
suggests putting hydrogen peroxide in a nebulizer
for lung issues. Someone named Dr. Becky
Campbell puts. This is not medical advice, but
did you know you can put colloidal silver and even
hydrogen peroxide in a nebulizer? It can help your
body fight off pathogens systemically and can
be very effective. This is another dangerous,
unproven idea. And we have a proven approved
vaccine. OK, the AFA is practically begging
people to pass on this, do not put hydrogen
peroxide into your nebulizer and breathe it in.
This is dangerous. It is not a way to prevent nor
treat covid. It is unclear where this originated,
experts agree it's a really bad idea. Look at
this. Jamie Allen, Ph.D., associate professor
of pharmacology and toxicology at Michigan
State, says hydrogen peroxide is a free radical,
meaning it's an unstable atom that can damage
cells if it's inhaled. It goes to the lungs where
it can damage cell membranes. It can even get into
the cells once the cell membranes are compromised
and can damage DNA. If you inhaled too much,
you can do major damage to your lungs. You
can also struggle with breathing normally and may
develop fluid in your lungs, a condition known as
a pulmonary edema. EMESH Adalja, M.D., scholar at
Johns Hopkins, says, I'm not even sure why people
have stumbled upon this. There's no evidence
it can work to treat covid it can be dangerous,
especially if you have sensitive lungs. Hydrogen
peroxide can kill covid on surfaces, but inhaling
it is a different story. This is basically
like Trump's hit the body with an injection
of disinfectant, right? I mean, it's OK. You might
have a surface and something can kill covid there.
So what about putting it inside the body, as
he likes to say? Doesn't apply, doesn't apply,
and it doesn't translate. And again, part of this
is just contrarianism. What I mean by that is
they say, I don't know what's in the vaccine,
so I'm not putting it in my body. It hasn't been
studied enough, so I'm not putting it in my body.
But then they'll accept unknown or at least in
these contexts, unstudied substances. And really,
what it comes down to is Biden's recommending
the vaccine. Biden's not recommending hydrogen
peroxide vapor or ivermectin or Betadine iodine
and it's contrarianism because they will accept
unknown or unstudied substances as long as it's
not the one a Democrat is recommending. But
this is still the issue of they want to say,
you can't tell me what to do. That's the you know,
they they claim that the principles are unstudied,
don't know what's in it, chemicals, cetera.
Really, the principle principle is you can't
tell me what to do. I'm not going to follow
the medical advice of public health officials
or of doctors, but then random people on Facebook
like this naturopathic doctor with an inhaler,
nebulizer says, hey, here's an idea, not medical
advice, but here's an idea of something you can do
and that they seem to gladly be
following. This is a crisis of education.
This is a crisis of critical thinking.
And if you are the type of person
who may even have compromised lungs already
and would be particularly at risk by
nebulizer and hydrogen peroxide, really you should
be vaccinated because you're at risk of more
serious covid. That's the bottom line. We've said
it a million times. I don't know how many more
times can I really repeat it. I have a feeling
it'll probably be a few more times. All right.